I had to turn my brain off because I had
been dwelling on a few things too
heavily over the past week so I I took a
break and I watched Miss Universe last
night yeah everyone Miss France because
she was the only the only person who
actually answered a question yeah you
know and I and then all these Filipinos
are kind of like ragging on the
Philippine contestant cuz she English is
not her first language and she had the
translator there but she instead chose
insisted to answer in English and oh my
god I couldn't even look at the TV
I mean Korea never makes it so sorry
because that we we choose the like a
yellow stick figure like this is a
yellow stick man up there I mean like
yeah it's never hard yeah but you guys
can we just find the video of her
answering this but Miss Philippines yeah
yep I don't want to like surprise they
chose someone that doesn't speak English
so no she is beautiful you know she's
that's the thing it's like they always
say like women empowerment but it just
sometimes doesn't feel like that when
you're watching I mean the woman who
want Miss Universe she's she's
identities and dentist dentistry you
know these girls do stuff with their
lives but I'm saying like how its
presented like the optics of it doesn't
feel like women empowerment you know
it's just it's kind of like it's just a
multi-million dollar business I think
that they just you know but it's also I
don't know forget it no I I can't say
[ __ ] king woke us woke us all I'll say I
say it as a slurp King okay so it's not
yes not Bobby yeah yeah I'll say this
love King I'm ba-ba-ba-ba is one person
slept King is the other one how can you
vote without seeing the vagina you said
this the last slap King you can't say
that slapping Bobbie Lee if you win if
they have a disaster down there how is
that definitely 90% good
yeah you might be worse than wrong why
why Wyatt because even he wouldn't say
that it's a truism though it's not a
business what are you hitting me hate
that you just said that all right but
you hit the slip King not Bobby but
before we do let's just do well on this
verse I can do I just so that I could
just get out of the way and then and
then we can move on with that okay is
what was so wrong about what I said that
you should we should be judging women by
the look of their vagina so Lee did I
say that like how can you know how can
you take a winner it's a part it's a
part of it right even if it's 2% of it
right of the vote right so if you're
down to two women they both had pretty
good answers they're both very very
attractive right you should have like a
deadlock thing let's see for vagina make
what one of them is like like a flower
and tie it and the one of them looks
like [ __ ] jazz hands you go look into
the flower it would be your three
criteria oh I mean that's very important
okay first of all we have to know what
it is sometimes you look at a vagina
doesn't even look like vagina so that's
out already you're already a limited
it's funny that your penis looks like a
vagina though that's fine I'm not mr.
universe voting for that you would be
Miss Universe with your vagina's what
I'm saying with a you thought about yeah
can i play the plan okay here we go
diri hired Steve harder baby harder
you [ __ ] up last year it wasn't
actually his [ __ ] it wasn't it wasn't
no he did all right
and also I have a thing against him but
go ahead yeah we talked about I know
let's [ __ ] it up King though so weird
that he doesn't find any Asian men like
what dateable but he's in Asia I know
Filipinos are so forgiving or like yeah
it's shot in the Philippine it's in the
Philippines this is why this makes it
more painful because I wanted her to use
if she just spoke Tagalog she would have
killed it yeah and but there's this idea
that oh if you know because Philippines
you know most people in the Philippines
speak English that she should answer in
English but that's not sure not
everybody has access to private school
not everybody can think politics and
culture in English everyone has baseline
English back home but not not enough
English to discuss politics and culture
you know it's like very anyways here go
[Music]
translator for a second that can't be
any form of language on planet Earth can
I just say right now a lot of Tagalog
that suddenly bobby's a person no it's
like this it's like the thing [ __ ]
rocks beautiful hold on hold on the
question was yeah I already know what
the question is okay in the last 10
years was the most significant change
yeah Jesus craze so the question was let
me just I just would need to figure this
off now I forgot the question you know I
was so thrown off by the answer right so
in the last 10 years what is the most
significant change you've seen that we
are one together
there in this world in this world is
basically answer okay here's what I want
to do we're gonna do okay cuz you're on
the spot right you have 30 seconds to
answer the question okay Bobby
stand over there you're Miss Philippines
K and up come on you have 30 seconds to
answer this question any question
ya know I'm gonna be the same one ready
no no give me a because I already know
my so give me a difference I want to see
how I can work under pressure
oh right yeah because they don't know
the answer Orion yeah so if I've already
had thought time that I think about the
answer so give me a question okay and
then maybe I could figure it I'll do the
final answer of Miss Universe ready
uh-huh
okay Miss Korea yes yes yes yes sir okay
yes yes name something during the course
of your life that you failed at and that
you learned from oh when I was 18 I
applied for to get a modeling agency and
everybody said that I wasn't hard enough
that I wasn't a cute enough and my
figure was too not like a model so I was
gonna quit but I didn't I knew that in
my dream I wanted to do this so I
persevered and I took all the you know
negative energy that people were putting
around me and I said you know what I'm a
human being I believe in this and I and
I did it and now I'm here Wow
Miss Korea second question that's pretty
good all right behind a second question
I got named a current or past world
leader whom you admire and why because
of the fact that you know for 400 year
they have a white president in every
time and you think that America you're
conditioned to only vote for a white
person but you know they as a collective
group they voted for the best qualified
person and um he I think that he changed
the world but just being our elected
you know why I can answer like that cuz
I'm not [ __ ] like these girls it's
so easy I swear to [ __ ] god it's
Suey's ask another one
January yes estimated 40 million people
yes worldwide for human rights yes
women's rights in other issue yes if you
were able to participate what would you
have been marching for oh I would be
watching obviously because be I was oh I
am a woman that I will be marching for
women's right but not just women's right
in America or in a specific place
women's red all over the world because
in Saudi Arabia women cannot even thrive
right so they are views about women are
a little bit more prehistoric or
medieval than my views so it should be a
grow I think you should be a globe or
you know make attention a woman's right
in general and we should combine the
we're all human beings and we all upon a
one vessel we are one vessel well the
same that killer it down I killed it got
word that Miss Korea is in fact comedian
Bobby we all right so so when I don't
know why I'm saying right now is that
question that she was asked is the most
simple turn Santa Clara and you can't
answer that show me your vagina see the
vagina
no because I'm vagina was like you don't
know what you just said what you win
for libel